أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمّية، اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM
Quantum. هذا هو الدرس العاشر في السلسلة والدرس الثاني في الوحدة الثالثة التي تتناول الصياغة العامة
للمعلومات الكمّية. هذا الدرس يتحدث عن القنوات التي تمثّل التغييرات في
الأنظمة التي تخزّن المعلومات الكمّية. يشمل ذلك العمليات المفيدة مثل تلك التي تنفّذها
بوابات gate الأحادية والدوائر circuit الكمّية، وكذلك التغييرات التي قد نفضّل تجنّبها مثل الضوضاء. يمكننا أيضاً وصف القياسات
كقنوات وهذا شيء سنتعمّق فيه في الدرس القادم. مصطلح "قناة" جاءنا من
نظرية المعلومات التي تدرس من بين أمور أخرى سعة نقل المعلومات لقنوات الاتصال
المشوّشة. فعندما نفكّر في القنوات فإننا نفكّر بشكل مجرّد في قنوات
الاتصال. قد يبدو غريباً بعض الشيء أن نعتبر عملية حسابية معقّدة قناة اتصال، لكننا نحتاج
كلمة للإشارة إلى المفهوم العام لعملية تغيّر المعلومات بطريقة ما، ولحسن الحظ أو لسوئه فإن كلمة
"قناة" قد رسخت، بلا شك بسبب التأثير الهائل لنظرية المعلومات وبالأخص
أعمال Claude Shannon في الأربعينيات على المعلومات والحوسبة الكمّية. إليكم نظرة عامة على
الدرس. سنبدأ بالأساسيات بما في ذلك تعريف ماهية القناة وكيف يمكن وصف العمليات الأحادية في الصياغة المبسّطة
للمعلومات الكمّية كقنوات. سنتحدث أيضاً عن حقيقة أن التوليفات المحدّبة للقنوات هي قنوات، وإذا كنتم
تتساءلون لماذا يستمر مفهوم التحدّب هذا بالظهور فذلك لأنه حقاً مفهوم رياضي أساسي جداً في نظرية
المعلومات الكمّية. سنرى أيضاً بعض الأمثلة على القنوات وتحديداً قنوات qubit التي ستظهر مجدداً من وقت
لآخر خلال بقية الدرس. في الجزء الثاني من الدرس سنتحدث عن ثلاث طرق مختلفة يمكننا بها تمثيل القنوات
رياضياً، وبالتحديد سنتحدث عن تمثيلات Stinespring وتمثيلات Kraus وتمثيلات Choi
المسمّاة على أسماء ثلاثة أشخاص كان عملهم مهماً في تطوير هذه التمثيلات المختلفة. وفي الجزء الثالث
والأخير من الدرس سنناقش برهاناً رياضياً يثبت أن هذه التمثيلات الثلاثة متكافئة فعلاً، وكذلك حقيقة أنها
جميعها توصّف بشكل صحيح تعريف ماهية القناة. إنه برهان رياضي رائع حقاً في رأيي وآمل أن يضيف بعض
الوضوح لهذه التمثيلات المختلفة وكيف ترتبط ببعضها وكيف تعمل بشكل عام. سنبدأ بالأساسيات و
نطرح السؤال: ما هي القنوات؟ كما أشرت في بداية الدرس، القنوات تصف التغييرات
وتحديداً التغييرات المنفصلة زمنياً في الأنظمة التي تخزّن المعلومات الكمّية. هنا عندما نشير إلى تغيير منفصل
زمنياً فإننا نفكّر ببساطة في تغيير يحدث بين لحظتين مختلفتين في الزمن بخلاف
عملية مستمرة مثلاً يكون من المنطقي التفكير فيها على فترات زمنية متناهية الصغر. تشمل القنوات عمليات مفيدة مثل
العمليات الأحادية التي تنفّذها بوابات gate ودوائر circuit كمّية، وكذلك التغييرات الناتجة عن الضوضاء مثلاً.
لكن لأغراض هذا الدرس سنفكّر في الغالب في القنوات بمصطلحات رياضية مجرّدة ولن تكون هناك حاجة خاصة
للتمييز بين ما هو مفيد وما ليس كذلك. الأسماء النموذجية للقنوات تشمل الأحرف اليونانية الكبيرة فاي
وساي وكاي، وسنستخدم أحرفاً مختلفة للإشارة إلى بعض القنوات المحددة. في حالة بسيطة يكون
لدينا نظام في حالة موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة رو ونطبّق قناة فاي على ذلك النظام، فإن
النتيجة هي نظام حالته موصوفة بمصفوفة الكثافة فاي(رو). فنحن نفكّر في قناة
معيّنة فاي كدالة يمكن تطبيقها على مصفوفات كثافة بحجم معيّن، أو بعبارة أخرى
مصفوفات كثافة لنظام معيّن نطبّق عليه هذه القناة. هناك شرطان يجب أن تستوفيهما القنوات لكي تُعتبر
قنوات صالحة. أولاً، القنوات هي تحويلات خطية. هذا مماثل تماماً للوضع الذي لدينا
في الصياغة المبسّطة للمعلومات الكمّية حيث العمليات على متجهات الحالة الكمّية هي بالضرورة خطية
وكذلك في الصياغة القياسية للمعلومات الكلاسيكية حيث العمليات الاحتمالية خطية. يمكنك أن تشكّك في هذا الشرط
الأساسي للخطية إن أردت فعلاً، لكن إن أردنا نظرية متسقة مع نظرية الاحتمالات
ومع اختيار تمثيل الحالات الكمّية بمصفوفات الكثافة فليس لدينا خيار آخر وعلينا ببساطة أن نقبل أن القنوات خطية.
الشرط الثاني هو أن القنوات تحوّل مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة. هذا منطقي تماماً لأننا إذا اخترنا تمثيل
حالات الأنظمة بمصفوفات الكثافة وطبّقنا قناة على نظام في حالة ما، فإن النتيجة يجب أن تكون حالة صالحة وبالتالي
ممثّلة بمصفوفة كثافة. لكن هناك نقطة مهمة جداً يجب إضافتها وهي أن هذا الشرط
يجب أن يكون صحيحاً ليس فقط إذا طبّقنا قناة على نظام معزول حالته موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة
بل أيضاً إذا كان لدينا نظام مركّب حالته موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة ما وطبّقنا القناة على جزء
فقط من ذلك النظام. هذه إذن هي الشروط التي نضعها على القنوات، ويمكننا أن نرى أنها مماثلة
جداً للشروط التي لدينا على العمليات في كل من الصياغة المبسّطة للمعلومات الكمّية والصياغة القياسية
للمعلومات الكلاسيكية. في الصياغة المبسّطة للمعلومات الكمّية تُمثَّل العمليات بمصفوفات أحادية لأنها
تتوافق تحديداً مع التحويلات الخطية التي تحوّل دائماً متجهات الحالة الكمّية إلى متجهات حالة كمّية لنظام
معيّن. وبالمثل تُمثَّل العمليات الاحتمالية بمصفوفات عشوائية لأن تلك هي التي
تحوّل دائماً متجهات الاحتمال إلى متجهات احتمال. هنا نعمل مع مصفوفات الكثافة وهناك
هذا الشرط الإضافي المتعلق بالأنظمة المركّبة الذي اتضح أنه ليس ضرورياً لمتجهات الحالة الكمّية
أو متجهات الاحتمال، لكن فيما عدا ذلك فإن الشروط متماثلة وبمعنى ما مفروضة علينا باختيار
تمثيل الحالات الكمّية بمصفوفات الكثافة. إليكم بعض التفاصيل الإضافية عن القنوات بما في ذلك اصطلاح
لكيفية التفكير في أنظمة الإدخال والإخراج لقناة ما خلال الدرس، وكذلك مزيد من التفاصيل
عن شرط أن القنوات تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة. أولاً، كل قناة يُفترض
أن لها نظام إدخال ونظام إخراج. يمكننا تسمية هذه الأنظمة كما نشاء، لكن خلال هذا
الدرس سأستخدم الاسم X للإشارة إلى نظام الإدخال والاسم Y للإشارة إلى نظام الإخراج. من الناحية المفاهيمية، القناة
تحوّل نظام الإدخال إلى نظام الإخراج، فنظاما الإدخال والإخراج لا يتواجدان في نفس الوقت.
نبدأ بـ X ثم تُطبَّق القناة أو تُنفَّذ والنتيجة هي أن X قد تحوّل إلى Y الذي حالته
تتحدد بالتحويل الخطي المرتبط بالقناة. لا يلزم أن يكون نظاما الإدخال والإخراج لقناة متماثلين وبالتحديد
لا يلزم أن يكون لهما نفس عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية. لكن قد يكون نظاما الإدخال والإخراج هما في الواقع نفس النظام، أو بعبارة
أخرى X يساوي Y، وفي هذه الحالة نتخيّل ببساطة أن فاي تغيّر حالة النظام، وهذا بالفعل هو
الوضع الذي نهتم به في كثير من الأحيان. لكن هذا الاحتمال متسق مع النقطة الأولى بمعنى أننا لا نملك
نظامي الإدخال والإخراج موجودين كنظامين منفصلين في نفس الوقت. وعلى أي حال سيكون من المناسب
لأغراض هذا الدرس استخدام أحرف مختلفة وهي X وY للإشارة إلى نظامي الإدخال والإخراج
فقط لمساعدتنا على إبقاء الأمور واضحة. الآن لنتعمّق أكثر في شرط أن القنوات تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات
الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة. لنفترض أننا أدخلنا نظاماً جديداً Z في الصورة، ولنسمِّ
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لهذا النظام الجديد غاما. تخيّلوا الآن أننا نشكّل نظاماً مركّباً جديداً ZX
يتكوّن من النظام الجديد مع نظام الإدخال X لقناة فاي، وافترضوا أن هذا النظام المركّب
في حالة موصوفة بمصفوفة كثافة رو. يمكن أن تكون هذه أي حالة كمّية لهذا الزوج، لكن مهما كانت الحالة
فمن الممكن دائماً التعبير عن مصفوفة الكثافة رو بالشكل المعروض على الشاشة، حيث كل من A وB
يأخذان قيماً من مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية غاما، وكل رو AB هي مصفوفة ما صفوفها وأعمدتها تتوافق مع
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X. ولا نحتاج لتسمية تلك المجموعة في هذه المرحلة. للتوضيح، كل رو AB ليست بالضرورة
مصفوفة كثافة بمفردها، لكن المصفوفة الكاملة رو هي بالضرورة مصفوفة كثافة. عندما نطبّق القناة فاي على
النظام X فإنه يتحوّل إلى Y وبالتالي يتبقى لدينا الزوج ZY، والطريقة التي نحدد بها
حالة هذا الزوج بعد تنفيذ فاي على X فقط هي بحساب التحويل الخطي فاي على كل من المصفوفات رو AB.
طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أننا نأخذ الجداء التنسوري للتحويل فاي مع تحويل الهوية على المصفوفات المربعة ذات الصفوف والأعمدة
المتوافقة مع غاما، وهذا بدوره يعادل عدم فعل أي شيء للنظام الجديد Z. لكن هذا وصف مكافئ
ولا يستلزم الخوض في أي تفاصيل حول الجداءات التنسورية للتحويلات من هذا الشكل.
لكنها تعمل بطريقة مباشرة جداً مماثلة لكيفية عملها مع المتجهات والمصفوفات. إحدى طرق التفكير في هذا بصرياً هي
من حيث المصفوفات الكتلية. وإذا وضعنا الافتراض المبسّط بأن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية غاما تتكوّن من
الأعداد الصحيحة بين 0 وN ناقص واحد لعدد صحيح موجب M، فيصبح من السهل كتابة كل هذا كما هو
موضّح هنا. والآن لنعيد التأكيد على الشرط الذي نضعه على فاي لكي تكون قناة صالحة: يجب أن نحصل دائماً على مصفوفة
كثافة من هذه العملية، ويجب أن يكون هذا صحيحاً بغض النظر عن اختيارنا للنظام Z وكذلك
اختيارنا لرو شرط أن تكون مصفوفة كثافة. قد يبدو هذا شرطاً صارماً جداً وقد
يبدو أيضاً أنه صعب التحقق منه جداً، لكن كما سنرى بنهاية الدرس فهو في الحقيقة ليس بهذه الصرامة
أو الصعوبة في التحقق، وبالتحديد لدينا توصيفات رياضية جيدة لهذا الشرط
مرتبطة بالتمثيلات المختلفة التي سنتحدث عنها لاحقاً في الدرس. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على بعض أمثلة القنوات
بدءاً بفئة كاملة من القنوات تسمى القنوات الأحادية. بعبارات بسيطة هذه هي العمليات
الأحادية تماماً كما في الصياغة المبسّطة للمعلومات الكمّية لكن منظوراً إليها كقنوات. بالتحديد، لنفترض أن U مصفوفة أحادية
تمثّل عملية أحادية على نظام X. ففي الصياغة المبسّطة للمعلومات
الكمّية كنا سنضرب هذه المصفوفة في متجه حالة كمّية معيّن لتحديد تأثير تلك العملية على تلك الحالة الكمّية.
الطريقة التي يعمل بها هذا مع مصفوفات الكثافة هي أننا نضرب مصفوفة الكثافة من اليسار بـ U ومن اليمين بـ U
المرافقة. بالمصطلحات الرياضية نسمّي هذه العملية القرينة بالمصفوفة U. هذا متسق مع كون كيت ساي
برا ساي هي مصفوفة الكثافة التي تصف الحالة الممثّلة بمتجه الحالة الكمّية ساي، ومن السهل جداً
التحقق من أنه بالتحديد إذا طبّقنا U على متجه الحالة الكمّية كيت ساي فسنحصل على U ضرب كيت ساي و
تمثيلها بمصفوفة كثافة يُعطى بذلك المتجه مضروباً في مرافقه المنقول وهو U ضرب كيت ساي ضرب برا ساي ضرب U
المرافقة عندما نحسب المرافق المنقول لـ U ضرب كيت ساي. فطريقة تعريف هذه القناة
منطقية للحالات النقية، وعندما ندمج هذا مع الخطية نرى أنه منطقي لمصفوفات الكثافة
بشكل عام نظراً لحقيقة أن كل مصفوفة كثافة يمكن التعبير عنها كتوليفة محدّبة من الحالات النقية. هذا
التعريف يعطينا دائماً قناة صالحة لأي اختيار لعملية أحادية U. بالتحديد، القرينة بمصفوفة
أحادية كهذه لا تغيّر أثر المصفوفة، وإذا أجرينا القرينة لأي مصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف
بأي مصفوفة على الإطلاق سنحصل على مصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف أخرى، ومن السهل جداً استنتاج ذلك
مباشرة من تعريف المصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف. فمصفوفات الكثافة تُحوَّل دائماً إلى مصفوفات
كثافة، وكل هذا يبقى صحيحاً حتى لو أخذنا الجداء التنسوري لـ U مع مصفوفة الهوية بأي حجم، وهو ما يعادل
تطبيق هذه القناة على جزء فقط من نظام مركّب. إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً جداً لقناة أحادية: لنفترض أننا
أخذنا U نفسها لتكون مصفوفة الهوية. هذه بوضوح قناة صالحة تسمى قناة الهوية. عدم فعل
أي شيء هو بالتأكيد عملية خطية، وإذا بدأنا بمصفوفة كثافة ولم نفعل بها شيئاً فستبقى
مصفوفة كثافة، لذا هذه قناة صالحة. يستخدم الناس رموزاً مختلفة للإشارة إلى هذه القناة،
أحياناً يكون نفس الرمز الذي نستخدمه لمصفوفة الهوية وهو ما قد يكون مربكاً قليلاً لكنه عموماً ليس كذلك. هنا أستخدم
الحرفين ID اختصاراً لـ identity فقط لتجنب أي لبس، وهذا الترميز شائع أيضاً. قد تبدو
قناة مملة جداً، لكن في سياق نقل المعلومات هي في الواقع قناة مثالية حيث يحصل
المستقبِل على ما يرسله المرسِل بالضبط وهو عادة ما يريده المرء أكثر في ذلك السياق. طريقة أخرى يمكننا بها
الحصول على أمثلة كثيرة للقنوات هي أخذ توليفات محدّبة من القنوات، أو بعبارة أخرى حساب متوسطاتها
معاً، وحقيقة أننا نستطيع فعل ذلك هي جانب مهم من القنوات. لشرح هذا بمزيد من التفصيل، لنبدأ بقناتين فاي₀ وفاي₁
لنقل، مع عدد حقيقي p بين 0 و1. وللتوضيح نفترض أن هاتين القناتين لهما
نفس نظام الإدخال وهو X وكذلك نفس نظام الإخراج وهو Y. والآن تأملوا ما يحدث إذا قررنا
تطبيق القناة الأولى فاي₀ باحتمال p وإلا بالاحتمال المتبقي 1 ناقص p نطبّق
القناة الثانية فاي₁. مثلاً ربما نختار بتاً عشوائياً بتلك الاحتمالات ثم نستخدم هذا البت
العشوائي لتحديد أي قناة نطبّق. بفعل ذلك نكون فعلياً نطبّق قناة جديدة يمكن تسميتها ساي
وهي توليفة محدّبة من القناتين اللتين بدأنا بهما، ويمكن التعبير عنها كما هو مكتوب
على الشاشة. يمكننا دائماً أخذ توليفات خطية من التحويلات الخطية بهذه الطريقة بالمناسبة، والطريقة التي تُعرَّف بها التوليفة
الخطية للتحويلات الخطية على مدخل معيّن هي ببساطة أخذ نفس التوليفة الخطية للمخرجات.
قد يبدو ذلك بديهياً لكنه منطقي. المخرج الذي نحصل عليه من هذا السيناريو الافتراضي هو ببساطة
المتوسط الموزون لمخرجات القناتين الأصليتين. مع ذلك هذه قناة جديدة و
إذا كانت فاي₀ وفاي₁ قناتين صالحتين فعلاً فمن المؤكد أن هذا التحويل الجديد سيكون أيضاً قناة صالحة. طريقة أخرى لقول
ذلك بالمصطلحات الرياضية هي أن مجموعة كل القنوات من نظام إدخال معيّن إلى نظام إخراج معيّن هي
محدّبة، وهذه خاصية رياضية مهمة للقنوات. يمكننا فعل هذا بشكل أعم إذا كان لدينا M قناة فاي₀ إلى فاي M ناقص واحد
مع متجه احتمالي يخبرنا بالاحتمال لكل قناة، فنحصل على قناة جديدة بحساب متوسط القنوات وفقاً لذلك.
فبمعنى ما هذا مصدر لا ينتهي لقنوات جديدة. مثلاً، فئة ما يُسمى بالقنوات الأحادية المختلطة هي ما
نحصل عليه بأخذ توليفات محدّبة من القنوات الأحادية. أي إذا كان لدينا M مصفوفة أحادية U₀ إلى U M ناقص
واحد جميعها بنفس الحجم مع متجه احتمالي، فإذا أخذنا المتوسط الموزون للقنوات
المتوافقة مع المصفوفات الأحادية الفردية كما هو موضّح على الشاشة، فسنحصل على قناة. والقنوات
التي يمكن كتابتها بهذا الشكل تسمى قنوات أحادية مختلطة. ليست كل قناة قناة أحادية مختلطة، لا يمكننا الحصول على
كل قناة بهذه الطريقة، لكنها تظهر كثيراً. بعد ذلك سنلقي نظرة على بعض الأمثلة
المحددة للقنوات. ستكون جميعها أمثلة لقنوات من qubit واحد إلى qubit واحد والتي تسمى قنوات
qubit اختصاراً. الأولى تسمى قناة إعادة تعيين qubit والفكرة هي أن هذه القناة تعيد تعيين qubit
إلى حالة الصفر. هنا نستخدم الحرف اليوناني الكبير لامدا للإشارة إلى هذه القناة، والطريقة لتذكّر ما تفعله هذه القناة هي أن
تفكّر في كرة بلوخ. الحرف لامدا الكبير يشبه سهماً يشير للأعلى وحالة الصفر في أعلى كرة بلوخ، فكأنه
يشير إلى موقع المخرج. التعريف بالمصطلحات الرياضية هو أن لامدا(رو) تساوي أثر رو ضرب كيت 0 برا 0.
فإذا حسبناها على أي مصفوفة كثافة رو سنحصل على حالة الصفر كمصفوفة كثافة. من الطبيعي التساؤل
لماذا نحتاج الأثر. ألا يمكننا ببساطة تعريف لامدا(رو) لتكون كيت 0 برا 0 بدون أثر رو في المقدمة؟
والجواب هو لا. القنوات يجب أن تكون تحويلات خطية ولن تكون خطية إذا أزلنا أثر رو. أيضاً تذكّروا أنه
أحياناً نحتاج معرفة كيف تعمل القناة كتحويل خطي على مدخلات ليست مصفوفات كثافة، مثلاً كما
رأينا سابقاً إذا أردنا معرفة ما تفعله القناة عند تطبيقها على نظام مركّب فنحتاج إلى
حساب تلك القناة على الكتل الفردية لمصفوفة كتلية أكبر. وعلى الرغم من أن المصفوفة الكتلية الكاملة قد تكون
مصفوفة كثافة فإن الكتل الفردية عموماً لن تكون كذلك. لنرَ بالضبط ما تفعله هذه القناة عند تطبيقها
على جزء واحد فقط من نظام مركّب، وبالتحديد ما تفعله عند تطبيقها على واحد من qubit-ين يشكّلان
وحدة ebit. بالتحديد، لنفترض أن A وB هما qubit-ان يكونان كزوج في حالة Bell فاي بلس ونطبّق لامدا
على qubit الأول A مثلاً. لمعرفة ما يحدث لنعبّر أولاً عن حالة فاي بلس كمصفوفة كثافة و
لأغراض هذا المثال لنستخدم ترميز ديراك لفعل ذلك. ها هي حالة فاي بلس كمتجه حالة كمّية وها هو ما نحصل عليه عندما
نضرب هذا المتجه في مرافقه المنقول ونوسّعه بالكامل. يمكننا بعدها تطبيق القناة على qubit الأول وحساب ما نحصل عليه. ها هي
لامدا مطبّقة على qubit الأول وها هو ما نحصل عليه عند حساب كل حد. أثر كيت 0 برا 0 يساوي واحداً
وكذلك أثر كيت 1 برا 1، ففي هاتين الحالتين مخرج القناة هو كيت 0 برا 0 وهذا يفسّر
الحدّين في الجواب. أثر كيت 0 برا 1 من جهة أخرى يساوي صفراً وكذلك أثر كيت 1 برا 0،
وبالتالي هذان الحدّان يساويان صفراً ولا يساهمان في الجواب. يمكننا الآن التبسيط
قليلاً وما نحصل عليه هو حالة الصفر لـ qubit الأول وهو A والحالة المختلطة تماماً لـ
qubit الثاني وهو B. لاحظوا بالتحديد أننا لم نحصل على حالة بلس لـ B، وهو ما لم يكن بالضرورة
تخميناً سيئاً لو لم نكن نعرف شيئاً عن مصفوفات الكثافة ونظرنا فقط إلى تمثيل متجه الحالة الكمّية للحالة. لكن هذه ليست
طريقة عمل هذه القناة وليس هناك أي قناة يمكن أن تعمل بهذه الطريقة. القناة لامدا تسمى قناة إعادة تعيين qubit لكن
طريقة عملها هي أشبه برمي qubit المدخل في سلة المهملات واستبداله بـ qubit جديد في حالة الصفر. لكن هذه في الحقيقة هي
قناة qubit الوحيدة التي تخرج دائماً حالة الصفر. ها هو مثال آخر على قناة qubit يُعرف بقناة
إزالة الطور الكاملة. يُرمز لها بدلتا وطريقة عملها هي أنها تترك العناصر القطرية
لأي مصفوفة 2×2 كما هي وتصفّر العناصر غير القطرية. دلتا هو الحرف اليوناني المكافئ لحرف D في
الأبجدية اللاتينية واختصار لـ diagonal، فهذه طريقة لتذكّر ما تفعله هذه القناة. يمكننا
بدلاً من ذلك التعبير عن هذه القناة باستخدام ترميز ديراك كما هو موضّح على الشاشة. وللتوضيح، المخرج
هو دائماً مصفوفة 2×2، فبالتحديد المخرجان الصفريان يشيران إلى مصفوفة 2×2 الصفرية بالكامل. كثيراً ما
نفعل هذا وقد رأيناه سابقاً في هذه السلسلة. الرمز صفر يُستخدم عموماً ربما بشكل غامض ليعني العنصر
الصفري لأي شيء نتحدث عنه سواء كانت كميات قياسية أو متجهات أو مصفوفات أو غير ذلك. لنفعل نفس ما فعلناه سابقاً مع
قناة إعادة تعيين qubit ونرى ما يحدث إذا طبّقنا هذه القناة على نصف وحدة ebit. الإعداد نفسه لذا لن أتناول
ذلك الجزء. والنتيجة هي الحالة المعروضة على الشاشة وهي أساساً بت عشوائي مشترك. فما
فعلته هذه القناة هو تحويل وحدة ebit إلى زوج مترابط تماماً من البتات الكلاسيكية العشوائية
وهذا متسق مع تفسير أعم لهذه القناة. بتصفير العناصر غير القطرية لمصفوفة الكثافة نكون فعلياً
نتخلص من الجانب الكمّي في مصفوفة الكثافة تاركين مصفوفة كثافة قطرية تمثّل حالة
احتمالية كلاسيكية. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في هذا هي أن هذه القناة تمثّل قناة كلاسيكية مثالية خالية من الضوضاء تنقل بتاً واحداً.
فإذا أدخلنا حالة صفر أو حالة واحد أو توليفة محدّبة من هاتين الحالتين في القناة فإن تلك الحالة تخرج دون تغيير. لكن إذا حاولتم
إدخال حالة كمّية مثل حالة بلس مثلاً فكأن القناة تقيس تلك الحالة بقياس الأساس القياسي ثم
تنقل النتيجة الكلاسيكية. مثال أخير على قناة qubit هو قناة إزالة الاستقطاب الكاملة. ما
تفعله هذه القناة هو إخراج الحالة المختلطة تماماً دائماً. فهي مشابهة بمعنى ما لقناة إعادة تعيين
qubit إلا أننا نحصل على حالة مختلطة تماماً أقل فائدة بدلاً من qubit مهيّأ. الطريقة الطبيعية
للتفكير في هذه القناة هي أنها تمثّل شكلاً متطرفاً من الضوضاء. وبالنسبة لقنوات qubit
فلا يوجد ما هو أكثر ضوضاء من هذا. ليس لدي وسيلة تذكّر جيدة لمشاركتها لتذكّر ما تفعله هذه القناة سوى القول بأن أوميغا هو الحرف
الأخير في الأبجدية اليونانية ويُرتبط أحياناً بنهاية كل شيء، وربما هذا ما يحدث
لكل qubit في النهاية. من ناحية الضوضاء فهي متطرفة جداً. لكن شيء يمكننا فعله هو النظر في توليفة محدّبة
من هذه القناة وقناة الهوية مع احتمال صغير ربما إبسيلون لإزالة الاستقطاب
الكاملة. هذا شكل أقل تطرفاً من الضوضاء حيث تُترك حالة qubit معيّنة في الغالب كما هي لكن هناك
بعض الاحتمال الصغير لأن تصبح مختلطة تماماً. هندسياً يمكننا التفكير في هذا كانكماش طفيف لكرة بلوخ نحو المركز.
وبالمناسبة يمكننا فعل شيء مماثل مع قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة لنمذجة عملية فقدان الترابط الكمّي مثلاً حيث تصبح الأشياء
أكثر كلاسيكية قليلاً عبر عملية ما. هذه ثلاثة أمثلة أساسية لقنوات qubit و
سنعود إليها بشكل رئيسي كمصدر للأمثلة خلال بقية الدرس. بعد ذلك سنناقش التمثيلات
الرياضية للقنوات بدءاً بسؤال أساسي. التحويلات الخطية من المتجهات إلى المتجهات يمكن دائماً
تمثيلها بمصفوفات بطريقة مألوفة، وهي أن فعل التحويل الخطي يوصف بضرب
المصفوفة في المتجه. لكن القنوات تحويلات خطية من مصفوفات إلى مصفوفات وليس من متجهات إلى متجهات. فكيف
يمكننا بشكل عام التعبير عن القنوات بمصطلحات رياضية؟ أحياناً للقنوات الخاصة سيكون لدينا صيغة بسيطة
تصفها وهذا ما حدث في أمثلة قنوات qubit التي ناقشناها بالفعل. لكن ذلك ليس
عملياً بشكل عام لأنه لن تكون هناك دائماً صيغة جميلة كهذه. كنقطة مقارنة، في الصياغة
المبسّطة للمعلومات الكمّية نستخدم مصفوفات أحادية لتمثيل العمليات على متجهات الحالة الكمّية.
كل مصفوفة أحادية تمثّل عملية صالحة وكل عملية صالحة يمكن التعبير عنها كمصفوفة أحادية. فما
يسأله هذا السؤال في جوهره هو كيف نفعل ذلك للقنوات. والجواب أن هناك في الحقيقة طرقاً متعددة لتمثيل
القنوات بمصطلحات رياضية. بالتحديد سنناقش ثلاث طرق مختلفة لتمثيل القنوات
مسمّاة على أسماء ثلاثة أشخاص لعب عملهم دوراً مهماً في تطويرها: Stinespring وKraus وChoi.
أولاً سنرى كيف تعمل هذه التمثيلات المختلفة، ثم في الجزء الأخير من الدرس سنرى كيف ترتبط التمثيلات الثلاثة وبالتحديد
كيف يمكننا التحويل بينها. سنرى أيضاً أن هذه التمثيلات تلتقط بدقة الشروط التي نضعها على القنوات
وهي أنها تحويلات خطية وأنها تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة حتى عند
تطبيقها على جزء فقط من نظام مركّب. أولاً تمثيلات Stinespring. كان W. Forrest Stinespring
عالم رياضيات لم يعمل في المعلومات الكمّية، وتمثيلات Stinespring كما سأصفها
هي بمعنى ما مشتقة من عمله في نظرية المؤثرات في الخمسينيات. لكن هذا العمل كان بالتأكيد
جزءاً مهماً من تطوير الرياضيات التي تقوم عليها القنوات الكمّية. الفكرة وراء هذه الطريقة لتمثيل القنوات هي أن كل
قناة يمكن تنفيذها بطريقة معيّنة سأصفها الآن. أولاً نشكّل نظاماً مركّباً يتكوّن من
مدخل أي قناة ننفّذها مع نظام مساحة عمل مهيّأ. ثم تُنفَّذ
عملية أحادية على النظام المركّب، وأخيراً الجزء من النظام المركّب الناتج
الذي يتوافق مع مخرج القناة يُترك كما هو أو يُخرَج والباقي يُتخلص منه أو يُحسب أثره الجزئي. من المفيد
التعبير عن هذا على شكل مخطط، والأبسط البدء بالحالة الخاصة التي يكون فيها نظاما الإدخال
والإخراج متماثلين. هذا المخطط بالمناسبة مثل مخطط circuit كمّي تماماً إلا أن الأسلاك
تمثّل أنظمة عشوائية وليس بالضرورة qubit-ات مفردة. فنبدأ بنظام الإدخال X في حالة
ما رو. نُدخل نظام مساحة عمل مهيّأ W وفي هذا المخطط أفترض أن صفر حالة كلاسيكية
لـ W ونأخذ كيت 0 كحالة مهيّأة للنظام، لكن يمكننا بدلاً من ذلك تثبيت أي حالة نقية
لـ W واعتبارها الحالة المهيّأة. ثم ننفّذ عملية أحادية ما على الزوج WX ثم
نحسب الأثر الجزئي لنظام مساحة العمل ونُخرج X. هنا في المخطط بالمناسبة أستخدم رمز الأرضي من
الهندسة الكهربائية للإشارة إلى أنه يتم التخلص من W. هذا ليس بالضرورة اصطلاحاً متعارفاً عليه ولن
تجدوا ذلك الرمز في Qiskit. هناك تتجاهلون ببساطة qubit-ات التي لا تهمكم. المقصود أنني فقط أريد رمزاً يوضّح
أننا نتخلص من النظام لأغراض هذا النقاش. بشكل عام لا يلزم أن يكون
نظاما الإدخال والإخراج متماثلين، فيمكن أن يكون لدينا مثلاً نظام إخراج Y مع نظام
نفايات G يُحسب أثره الجزئي. لكي تكون U أحادية يجب أن تكون مصفوفة مربعة، فهناك افتراض
هنا بأن الزوج GY معاً له نفس عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية كالزوج WX. مثلاً ربما تتكوّن هذه الأنظمة
من qubit-ات ونظام الإدخال X يتكوّن من 5 qubit-ات وW يتكوّن من 10 qubit-ات لنقل، فـ U عملية أحادية
على 15 qubit. يمكن أن يكون Y مكوّناً من 4 qubit-ات فقط مما يعني أن G يتكوّن من 11 qubit
أو ربما ليست هذه qubit-ات أصلاً. المهم أن WX معاً وGY معاً لهما نفس عدد
الحالات الكلاسيكية حتى تكون U أحادية. وصف قناة كهذا يسمى تمثيل Stinespring للقناة. والآن من
السهل نسبياً إثبات أن أي تحويل فاي يمكن وصفه بهذه الطريقة هو في الحقيقة قناة صالحة.
بالتحديد إذا بدأنا بمصفوفة كثافة ثم أضفنا نظام مساحة عمل إضافي فسنحصل بالتأكيد على
مصفوفة كثافة. لاحظنا سابقاً أن تطبيق عملية أحادية يعطينا قناة صالحة، و
إذا كانت لدينا مصفوفة كثافة لنظام مركّب وحسبنا الأثر الجزئي لأحد الأنظمة فسنحصل مجدداً على مصفوفة كثافة. فعندما نركّب
هذه الخطوات سيكون مضموناً أنها تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة وأنها خطية أيضاً.
ما ليس واضحاً أبداً في هذه المرحلة هو أن كل قناة يمكن فعلاً تنفيذها بهذه الطريقة لبعض الاختيارات
لنظام مساحة العمل ونظام النفايات وكذلك العملية الأحادية U طبعاً. لكن هذا صحيح و
سنرى السبب بنهاية الدرس. ها هو مثال على تمثيل Stinespring لقناة إزالة
الطور الكاملة لـ qubit. وللتوضيح الآن الأسلاك هي qubit-ات وهذه بوابة controlled-NOT
عادية. إنها بسيطة جداً. qubit المدخل في الأعلى وأدخلنا qubit مساحة عمل مهيّأ في حالة
الصفر. ثم ننفّذ عملية controlled-NOT حيث qubit المدخل هو التحكم وqubit مساحة العمل هو
الهدف، ثم يُحسب الأثر الجزئي لـ qubit مساحة العمل. بشكل حدسي من المنطقي
أن هذا ينفّذ قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة لأن بوابة controlled-NOT تعمل نوعاً ما كقياس أساس قياسي على qubit
الأعلى بنسخ حالته الكلاسيكية إلى qubit الأسفل ثم يُرمى الناتج
بعيداً. لكن يمكننا أيضاً إجراء حساب وبالطبع من الجيد فعل ذلك لأننا حقاً
لا ينبغي أن نثق كثيراً بحدسنا. يمكننا البدء بكتابة تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة لـ
qubit-ين بعد إدخال qubit مساحة العمل، ولاحظوا أننا نستخدم اصطلاح ترتيب Qiskit كالمعتاد
حيث qubit الأسفل هو الأيسر وqubit الأعلى هو الأيمن. يمكننا التعبير عن مصفوفة الكثافة هذه
صراحةً كمصفوفة 4×4 فعلية كما هو موضّح على الشاشة، ثم نحسب تأثير
بوابة gate controlled-NOT على مصفوفة الكثافة هذه. فنجري القرينة بالمصفوفة الأحادية المرتبطة بهذه
البوابة gate مع مراعاة اصطلاح ترتيب Qiskit مجدداً. فهذه هي المصفوفة الأحادية
الصحيحة والنتيجة موضّحة هنا. في الواقع بوابة gate controlled-NOT
أعادت ترتيب عناصر مصفوفتنا الأصلية قليلاً، فالآن العناصر التي قد تكون غير صفرية موجودة في
الأركان الأربعة. يبقى حساب الأثر الجزئي ويمكننا فعل ذلك مباشرة من المصفوفة، لكن
البديل هو التحويل إلى ترميز ديراك كما هو موضّح على الشاشة وعندها يصبح سهلاً جداً حساب
ما يحدث عندما نحسب الأثر الجزئي لـ qubit الأيسر في كل حد. والنتيجة أن الحدود
المتوافقة مع العناصر القطرية لرو فقط هي التي تبقى وبالتالي أزلنا طور qubit كما هو
متوقع. كالعادة تحققوا من ذلك بأنفسكم بالسرعة التي تناسبكم إن اخترتم ذلك. إنه مثال جيد
للتمرّن على العمل مع مصفوفات الكثافة ومع الآثار
الجزئية. هذه ليست الطريقة الوحيدة لتنفيذ قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة. ها هو تمثيل Stinespring بديل لهذه
القناة. لن أتناول الحساب بالتفصيل في هذا الفيديو لكنني سأعرضه باختصار في حال أردتم إيقاف الفيديو وإلقاء
نظرة أقرب. الطريقة التي يعمل بها مماثلة للأولى لكن التفاصيل
مختلفة. هذه المرة نبدأ ببوابة Hadamard على qubit مساحة العمل مما يضعه في حالة بلس، وإذا
وسّعنا الجداء التنسوري نحصل على المصفوفة الموضّحة على الشاشة. لتطبيق بوابة gate controlled-Z نجري
القرينة بالمصفوفة الأحادية المرتبطة بها، ونتيجة ذلك هي إدخال بعض إشارات السالب في
المصفوفة. بالتحديد الصف الأخير والعمود الأخير كلاهما يُضرب بسالب 1.
وهذه المرة سيكون التحويل إلى ترميز ديراك فوضوياً جداً لذا سنحسب الأثر الجزئي
مباشرة. عندما نحسب الأثر الجزئي لأول qubit من qubit-ين فإننا نحصل على مجموع الكتلتين القطريتين 2×2
والنتيجة النهائية مجدداً أننا أزلنا طور qubit. كان ذلك سريعاً وإن لم تكونوا
معتادين على هذا النوع من الحسابات فخذوا وقتكم وافعلوها ببطء. السرعة ليست مهمة
هنا. لإنهاء هذا المثال دعوني أذكر أن هناك فكرة بسيطة جداً وراء هذا التنفيذ وهي
معبّر عنها بشكل جميل في الخطوة الأخيرة من الحساب الذي مررنا عليه سريعاً. بطريقة أكثر اختصاراً
إذا أخذنا متوسط مصفوفة كثافة qubit معيّنة مع تلك المصفوفة بعد القرينة بمصفوفة Pauli Z فإن
ذلك يكافئ إزالة الطور. فقناة إزالة الطور الكاملة هي في الواقع قناة أحادية
مختلطة حيث إما لا نفعل شيئاً أي ننفّذ عملية الهوية أو ننفّذ بوابة Z gate كل
منهما باحتمال ½. معلومة جيدة. فباختصار لدينا تمثيلا
Stinespring مختلفان لقناة إزالة الطور الكاملة وهذا يخبرنا بشيء مهم وهو أن تمثيلات Stinespring
ليست وحيدة، وفي الحقيقة هناك عدد لانهائي منها لأي قناة معيّنة. بعد ذلك نناقش تمثيلات
Kraus للقنوات التي تعطينا طريقة صيغية مناسبة للتعبير عن القنوات من خلال ضرب
المصفوفات وجمعها. تمثيلات Kraus مسمّاة على اسم Karl Kraus وهو فيزيائي من بين
أمور أخرى عمل على كثير من التفاصيل الرياضية الأساسية للقنوات والصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمّية بشكل أعم. بشكل عام تمثيل
Kraus هو تعبير عن قناة بالشكل الموضّح على الشاشة. بالتحديد لدينا مجموعة
من المصفوفات المسمّاة هنا A₀ إلى A_ لعدد صحيح موجب n وهي تحدد
فعل القناة على أي مدخل رو وفقاً للصيغة. باختصار نجري القرينة لرو بكل من هذه المصفوفات
التي يُشار إليها عادة بمصفوفات Kraus في هذا السياق ثم نجمع النتائج وهذا يعطينا المخرج. كل هذه المصفوفات يجب أن تكون بنفس
الأبعاد وبالتحديد أعمدتها يجب أن تتوافق مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإدخال و
صفوفها يجب أن تتوافق مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإخراج. إذا كان ذلك محققاً فعندما نأخذ الجداء Aₖ ضرب رو ضرب Aₖ المرافقة لأي
اختيار لـ k نحصل على مصفوفة مربعة صفوفها وأعمدتها تتوافق مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإخراج
فمن المنطقي أن التعبير ينتج مصفوفة كثافة لنظام الإخراج. الآن ليس الحال أنه
لأي اختيار عشوائي لمصفوفات Kraus هذه نحصل على قناة صالحة. لكن هناك شرط بسيط جداً
على المصفوفات يضمن أننا سنحصل على قناة صالحة، وهذا الشرط هو الصيغة المعروضة هنا.
بالتحديد إذا جمعنا جداء Aₖ المرافقة ضرب Aₖ على كل قيم k
يجب أن نحصل على مصفوفة الهوية، وستكون مصفوفة الهوية التي صفوفها وأعمدتها تتوافق مع
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإدخال. فهذا الشرط يجب أن يتحقق لكي يكون التحويل المعرّف بالمعادلة
الأولى قناة صالحة. واتضح أن كل قناة لها فعلاً تمثيل بهذا الشكل
طالما أخذنا n كبيراً بما يكفي. ها هي بعض أمثلة تمثيلات
Kraus بدءاً بقناة إعادة تعيين qubit. يمكننا الحصول على تمثيل Kraus لهذه القناة باستخدام
مصفوفتي Kraus: كيت 0 برا 0 وكيت 0 برا 1. فـ n تساوي 2 في هذا المثال.
يمكننا التعويض بهذه الاختيارات في الصيغة العامة ولدينا حدّان فقط فمن السهل كتابة المجموع
وإذا بسّطنا وأدركنا أن التعبير بين القوسين هو أثر رو فنرى أننا نحصل على
قناة إعادة تعيين qubit. يمكننا أيضاً التحقق من أن الشرط المطلوب على هذه المصفوفات متحقق وهو مسألة بسيطة بالتعويض بمصفوفات Kraus
في المعادلة وحسابها ونحصل على مصفوفة الهوية كما هو مطلوب. لمثال آخر لنلقِ نظرة مجدداً على
قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة. أخذ المصفوفتين كيت 0 برا 0 وكيت 1 برا 1 يعمل ويمكن التحقق من ذلك بتوسيع
المجموع ورؤية أننا نحصل مباشرة على ما نحتاجه. ومجدداً الشرط المطلوب متحقق. البديل
هو أخذ A₀ لتكون مصفوفة الهوية مقسومة على جذر 2 وA₁ لتكون
سيغما Z مقسومة على جذر 2. وإذا حسبنا نرى أننا نحصل مجدداً على قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة بناءً على الملاحظة
التي ذكرناها عن هذه القناة قبل قليل في الدرس. ومجدداً الشرط المطلوب سهل التحقق
منه. كتمرين للعمل عليه إن وجدتم ذلك مفيداً، فكّروا في قناة إزالة الاستقطاب
الكاملة التي تخرج الحالة المختلطة تماماً لكل مصفوفة كثافة مدخلة. لهذه القناة أربع مصفوفات Kraus
مطلوبة. لا يمكن إيجاد تمثيل Kraus حيث n تساوي 3 أو أقل. ها هو اختيار يعمل و
ها هو اختيار آخر. فالتمرين هو التحقق من أن هذه الاختيارات تعمل وكذلك التحقق من أن الشرط المطلوب
متحقق. الجدير بالذكر أن البديل الثاني يقول أساساً أنه من الممكن إزالة استقطاب qubit بالكامل أو بعبارة أخرى
جعله عشوائياً تماماً باختيار عشوائي لإحدى مصفوفات Pauli الأربع بما فيها مصفوفة الهوية وتطبيق
العملية الأحادية المقابلة على qubit. وبالتالي فإن قناة إزالة الاستقطاب الكاملة هي مثال آخر على قناة أحادية
مختلطة. آخر تمثيلات القنوات الثلاثة التي سنتناولها هو تمثيل Choi. Man-Duen Choi
عالم رياضيات يعمل في نظرية المصفوفات ومواضيع أخرى، وتمثيل Choi مسمّى تكريماً له
استناداً إلى ورقة بحثية أنيقة حقاً نشرها في عام 1975 تربط كل هذه الأمور معاً بمعنى ما. تمثيل
Choi لقناة فاي هو مصفوفة واحدة يُرمز لها اصطلاحاً بـ J(فاي). وبالتحديد إذا كان
نظام الإدخال يملك n حالة كلاسيكية ونظام الإخراج يملك m حالة كلاسيكية فإن تمثيل Choi لفاي سيكون
مصفوفة مربعة n ضرب m في n ضرب m. قبل أن أخبركم بالضبط كيف تُعرَّف المصفوفة أود ذكر بعض
خصائصها الأساسية التي تبرر التمثيل بطريقة قد لا يفعلها التعريف الفعلي نفسه على الأقل
ظاهرياً. أولاً بخلاف كل من تمثيلات Stinespring وتمثيلات Kraus فإن تمثيل Choi
هو ما يسمى تمثيلاً أميناً مما يعني أن كل قناة لها تمثيل واحد فقط. وهذا مهم جداً
لأنه يعني أن قناتين متماثلتان إذا وفقط إذا كان تمثيلا Choi الخاصان بهما متماثلين. فإذا
كان لديكم وصفان مختلفان لقنوات مثل تمثيلي Stinespring مختلفين أو تمثيلي Kraus مختلفين أو ربما واحد من
كل منهما وأردتم معرفة إن كانا في الحقيقة نفس القناة، يمكنكم ببساطة حساب تمثيل Choi و
التحقق مما إذا كانا متساويين. الخاصية الثانية هي أن هناك شروطاً بسيطة يمكن التحقق منها على تمثيل Choi تكون صحيحة إذا وفقط
إذا كانت لدينا قناة صالحة. هذه الخاصية ليست مميزة تماماً، يمكننا قول الشيء نفسه عن التمثيلين الآخرين، لكنها خاصية جيدة
على أي حال وسنناقشها بمزيد من التفصيل قريباً. شيء آخر يجدر ذكره عن تمثيل Choi هو أنه رغم أننا
نمثّل قناة بمصفوفة فإن هذه المصفوفة لا تمثّل القناة مباشرة كتحويل خطي. في الحقيقة
من الأطبيعي ربط تمثيل Choi بمصفوفة الكثافة التي تمثّل حالة معيّنة
بدلاً من التفكير فيه كوصف لتحويل خطي. لكن من الممكن استرجاع فعل القناة من
تمثيل Choi الخاص بها باستخدام صيغة بسيطة جداً لكنها ليست بسيطة كضرب المصفوفات
العادي. هذا يكفي كمقدمة، لننتقل إلى التعريف الفعلي. لنفترض أن لدينا قناة فاي من نظام X إلى نظام Y
ولنفترض أن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإدخال X هي سيغما. لن نحتاج للإشارة إلى مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإخراج لذا
لا حاجة لتسمية تلك المجموعة للتعريف. تمثيل Choi لفاي يُعرَّف بالتعبير
الموضّح على الشاشة. لدينا مجموع يمتد على كل الحالات الكلاسيكية a وb لنظام الإدخال ونجمع
كيت a برا b منسوراً تنسورياً مع القناة فاي مطبّقة على كيت a برا b. فهذا
التمثيل معرّف بصيغة وهناك طريقتان مختلفتان للتفكير في هذه الصيغة. قبل مناقشتهما دعوني
أذكر أن تمثيل Choi يُعرَّف أحياناً بطريقة مختلفة قليلاً حيث يُعكس ترتيب العاملين التنسوريين بمعنى
أن فاي(كيت a برا b) يظهر كعامل تنسوري أول بدلاً من الثاني. لكن الطريقتين
متكافئتان حتى هذا التناظر البسيط. لكن ما يعنيه ذلك هو أنه عند استخدام هذا التمثيل من الجيد
توضيح أي ترتيب تستخدمون. هذا الترتيب هو الطريقة المتبعة في Qiskit وهو أيضاً أفضل لوصف
التمثيل بصرياً من حيث المصفوفات الكتلية لذا هذا ما سنتبعه. لمزيد من الدقة حول وصف المصفوفة الكتلية
إذا افترضنا أن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية سيغما تتكوّن من الأعداد الصحيحة من صفر إلى n ناقص 1
لعدد صحيح موجب n، فيمكننا بدلاً من ذلك كتابة J(فاي) كمصفوفة كتلية كما هو موضّح هنا على
الشاشة. بعبارة أخرى تمثيل Choi لفاي هو المصفوفة التي نحصل عليها بحساب فاي على كل من
مصفوفات الإدخال التي لها عنصر واحد بالضبط يساوي واحداً وبقية عناصرها صفر ثم ترتيبها
في مصفوفة بطريقة طبيعية جداً. قد لا يكون واضحاً مسبقاً لماذا نريد تشكيل مصفوفة كهذه لكن
اتضح أنها مفيدة جداً. شيء يمكن ملاحظته هو أن المجموعة المكوّنة من المصفوفات كيت a برا b حيث
a وb يأخذان جميع الأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى n ناقص 1 تشكّل أساساً لفضاء كل المصفوفات n في n. فإذا
كانت لديكم هذه المصفوفة فيمكنكم بالتأكيد تحديد ما تفعله فاي بأي مصفوفة n في n عشوائية بالخطية،
بالتحديد بأخذ التوليفات الخطية المناسبة من الكتل. فالمصفوفة J(فاي) تحدد فعلاً بشكل فريد
فاي كتحويل خطي. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في تمثيل Choi لقناة هي أنه
يمثّل حالة كمصفوفة كثافة عند تقييسه. بالتحديد بقسمته على عدد
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإدخال الذي سأستمر بالإشارة إليه بـ n الصغيرة. هذا سيعطينا دائماً
مصفوفة كثافة تُسمى غالباً حالة Choi للقناة. إليكم كيف يعمل هذا بمزيد من التفصيل.
تخيّلوا أولاً أن لدينا نسختين متطابقتين من نظام الإدخال ونعتبر متجه الحالة الكمّية المعروض
على الشاشة والذي يمثّل ما يسمى حالة متشابكة أقصوياً لهذا الزوج من الأنظمة المتطابقة. مثلاً
إذا كانت سيغما الأبجدية الثنائية فهذه حالة فاي بلس. لكن يمكننا التفكير في حالة معرّفة بشكل مماثل لأي
اختيار لسيغما وما نحصل عليه هو حالة شديدة التشابك وفي الحقيقة هي أقصى تشابك ممكن
بالنظر لهذا الاختيار من الأنظمة. للحصول على تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة للحالة نضرب متجه الحالة في مرافقه المنقول كالمعتاد و
هذا ما يبدو عليه. وأخيراً إذا فكّرنا في تمثيل Choi للقناة مقسوماً على n فنرى أنه الحالة التي
نحصل عليها لو طبّقنا القناة فاي على النظام الثاني. على شكل رسم ها هو
ما يبدو عليه. لدينا نسختان من النظام X في هذه الحالة المتشابكة أقصوياً. تُطبَّق القناة فاي
على النظام الثاني وهو الذي في الأعلى في المخطط. والحالة الناتجة هي حالة Choi لفاي. طبعاً لن نسمّي عادة
نظامين مختلفين بنفس الاسم فهذا عموماً ليس مفيداً. لكنه منطقي
في هذه الحالة فقط لإجراء هذا الربط مع تمثيلات Choi. هناك استنتاجان يمكننا استخلاصهما فوراً من هذه الطريقة
في النظر إلى تمثيلات Choi. الأول هو أنه بما أن حالة Choi هي مصفوفة كثافة بافتراض أن فاي
قناة صالحة، نستنتج أن تمثيل Choi لفاي يجب أن يكون شبه موجب التعريف. تذكّروا أنه
شرط نضعه على القنوات أن تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة وهذه
مجرد حالة خاصة من ذلك. الاستنتاج الثاني هو أنه إذا أخذنا حالة Choi لأي قناة فاي
ثم تخلّصنا من نظام الإخراج Y فيجب أن نحصل على الحالة المختلطة تماماً لنظام الإدخال X. وذلك
لأن تطبيق قناة على نظام ثم رمي النظام الناتج في سلة المهملات يكافئ ببساطة رمي النظام الأصلي في
سلة المهملات. ولو فعلنا ذلك مع حالتنا المتشابكة أقصوياً فإن مصفوفة الكثافة التي ستتبقى لدينا ستكون
مصفوفة الهوية مقسومة على n أو بعبارة أخرى الحالة المختلطة تماماً للنظام X. الفكرة بمصطلحات
رياضية أكثر هي أن تركيب أي قناة مع الأثر على نظام الإخراج يجب أن يساوي الأثر على نظام
الإدخال. وذلك لأن القنوات يجب أن تحافظ على الأثر بحكم كونها تحويلات خطية
تحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة. بمجرد حصولنا على هذه المعادلة يمكننا حذف المقام n
من الطرفين للحصول على شرط أنظف قليلاً. بكلمات: حساب الأثر الجزئي على نظام الإخراج
من تمثيل Choi لقناة يجب أن يعطينا مصفوفة الهوية على نظام الإدخال. فباختصار تمثيلات
Choi للقنوات هي دائماً شبه موجبة التعريف، وإذا حسبنا الأثر الجزئي لنظام الإخراج فسنحصل بالضرورة
على مصفوفة الهوية لنظام الإدخال. واتضح أن هذين ليسا شرطين ضروريين فحسب بل
هما كافيان أيضاً، بمعنى أنه إذا كان فاي تحويلاً خطياً عشوائياً وتحقق هذان الشرطان معاً
فيجب أن يكون فاي في الحقيقة قناة صالحة. وسنرى لماذا بنهاية الدرس.
لنلقِ نظرة على بعض الأمثلة بدءاً بقناة إزالة الطور الكاملة. لحساب تمثيل Choi نحتاج فقط لحساب
الصيغة. قناة إزالة الطور الكاملة تترك كيت a برا b كما هو عندما يكون a يساوي b وإلا يكون المخرج
صفراً. فالحدود في المجموع التي تبقى هي تلك التي a يساوي b والنتيجة معبّر عنها على
الشاشة بترميز ديراك. يمكننا أيضاً رؤيتها كمصفوفة كتلية. دلتا تترك العناصر القطرية كما هي وتصفّر العناصر
غير القطرية وبالتالي نحصل على مصفوفة بها واحدات في الركنين العلوي الأيسر والسفلي الأيمن مع كون جميع
عناصرها صفراً. وهذا متسق مع التعبير الأول. لمثال آخر لنعتبر قناة إزالة الاستقطاب الكاملة. مجدداً يمكننا
البدء بكتابة الصيغة. وتماماً كالمثال السابق لا نحصل على أي مساهمة في المجموع
عندما a لا يساوي b. وهذه المرة عندما a يساوي b نحصل على الحالة المختلطة تماماً ويمكننا تبسيط ذلك
للحصول على ½ ضرب مصفوفة الهوية 2×2 منسورة تنسورياً مع نفسها وهي ½ ضرب مصفوفة الهوية
4×4. يمكننا أيضاً التفكير فيها من حيث المصفوفات الكتلية وبطبيعة الحال نحصل على نفس النتيجة. و
كمثال أخير لنعتبر قناة الهوية لـ qubit واحد. إنها سهلة. ها هي الصيغة و
بالطبع قناة الهوية لا تفعل أي شيء على الإطلاق. ويمكننا التفكير في النتيجة على أنها ضعف مصفوفة الكثافة المرتبطة بحالة فاي بلس وهذا
متسق مع ما نتوقعه بالتفكير في حالة Choi لهذه القناة. وها هي كمصفوفة كتلية. لاحظوا بالتحديد أن تمثيل
Choi لقناة الهوية ليس مصفوفة الهوية بل هذه المصفوفة. لقد رأينا الآن ثلاث طرق مختلفة
لتمثيل القنوات بمصطلحات رياضية وهي تمثيلات Stinespring وتمثيلات Kraus وتمثيلات Choi.
ولدينا أيضاً تعريف القناة وهو أن القناة تحويل خطي يحوّل دائماً
مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة حتى عند تطبيق القناة على جزء فقط من نظام مركّب. سؤال طبيعي ومهم جداً
يمكن طرحه في هذه المرحلة هو: كيف نعرف أن كل هذه الأشياء متكافئة؟ مثلاً كيف نعرف أن كل
تحويل موصوف بأي من هذه التمثيلات هو فعلاً قناة صالحة؟ وكيف نعرف أننا لا نترك أي قنوات؟
بقية الدرس تصف كيف يمكن تبرير كل هذا رياضياً. إذا كنتم مستعدين لقبول تكافؤ هذه الأشياء ولا تهتمون بكيفية تبريرها
فلا تتردّدوا في تخطي بقية الفيديو. لكنني شخصياً أعتقد أن الحجة أنيقة جداً
وهي مثال جيد على أسلوب معيّن من البراهين الرياضية يظهر من وقت لآخر في نظرية المعلومات الكمّية. لن أتناول
كل التفاصيل، بعضها سأتركه لكم أو يمكنكم إيجادها في المحتوى المكتوب لهذا الدرس حيث كل شيء مكتوب
بالتفصيل. لكنني آمل أن أقدم صورة واضحة بشكل معقول لكيفية عمل كل ذلك. ما نريد فعله هو إثبات
تكافؤ مجموعة من العبارات، والطريقة التي يمكننا بها فعل ذلك هي بناء دورة من الاستلزامات. بالتحديد سنبدأ
بتعريف القناة أي تحويل خطي يحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة.
من هذا التعريف يمكننا استنتاج أن تمثيل Choi لهذه القناة يجب أن يستوفي الشرطين اللذين
ناقشناهما بالفعل، وفي الحقيقة فعلنا ذلك مسبقاً. تمت مناقشة هذا في سياق حالة Choi لقناة. ثم ننسى كل شيء
عن التعريف ونعمل من تمثيل Choi، وبناءً على شرطينا على تمثيلات Choi نستنتج أنه يجب أن يوجد
تمثيل Kraus للتحويل فاي. ثم نفعل شيئاً مماثلاً، ننسى تمثيلات Choi ونعمل
من تمثيل Kraus عشوائي ومنه نستنتج أنه يجب أن يوجد تمثيل Stinespring للتحويل فاي. وبالمناسبة هذه
الحجج ستكون آلية بمعنى ما مما يسمح لنا فعلاً بإجراء التحويلات وفقاً للأسهم لقنوات محددة إن أردنا
ذلك. الاستلزام الأخير هو استنتاج أنه إذا كان لدينا تمثيل Stinespring لتحويل فاي فإن
ذلك التحويل يجب أن يكون فعلاً قناة صالحة. ومجدداً فعلنا ذلك مسبقاً هذه المرة في سياق تمثيلات
Stinespring. هذه الاستلزامات الأربعة معاً تكشف أن هذه الأشياء الأربعة كلها متكافئة لأنه يمكنك البدء من أي منها و
اتباع الاستلزامات بشكل متعدّ للوصول إلى أي من الأخرى. سنبدأ بالاستلزام الأول
وهو أنه إذا كانت لدينا قناة فاي أي تحويل خطي يحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة فإن لها تمثيل Choi
يستوفي الشرطين اللذين حددناهما سابقاً وهما أنه شبه موجب التعريف
وإذا حسبنا الأثر الجزئي لنظام الإخراج نحصل على مصفوفة الهوية لنظام الإدخال. وكما ذكرت قبل قليل
تناولنا هذا الاستلزام مسبقاً في سياق حالات Choi. بالتحديد عندما نقسم تمثيل Choi لقناة على n عدد
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام الإدخال نحصل على مصفوفة كثافة، وعلاوة على ذلك الحالة المختزلة لنظام
الإدخال X لتلك الحالة هي الحالة المختلطة تماماً أو بعبارة أخرى مصفوفة الهوية مقسومة على n. حذف المقام يعطينا
شرطينا. فهذا الاستلزام سريع وسهل جداً لأننا تناولناه
مسبقاً. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على الاستلزام الثاني. هذه المرة نبدأ بتمثيل Choi لتحويل نفترض
أنه يستوفي الشرطين، وهدفنا إيجاد تمثيل Kraus لهذا التحويل يستوفي
الشرط الذي تحدثنا عنه سابقاً. هذا الاستلزام آلي بمعنى ما. سنحتاج قليلاً
من الجبر الخطي وسيتلخص الأمر بشكل رئيسي في التعامل مع المصفوفات والمتجهات بطريقة ذكية
جداً. يبدأ بافتراض أن تمثيل Choi شبه موجب التعريف وهو أول الشرطين اللذين
نفترض تحققهما. مفهوم المصفوفة شبه الموجبة التعريف مهم بشكل جوهري في المعلومات الكمّية وليس فقط في سياق مصفوفات
الكثافة. إنه حاسم تماماً هنا، لن نتمكن من إنجاح هذا بدونه. بالتحديد افتراض
أن J(فاي) شبه موجبة التعريف يسمح لنا بالتعبير عنها بالشكل الموضّح على الشاشة لبعض الاختيارات من
المتجهات s₀ إلى s_ ولبعض الأعداد الصحيحة الموجبة n. ودعوني أنوّه صراحة أن هذه
ليست بالضرورة متجهات وحدة. إحدى الطرق للحصول على تعبير كهذا هي من المبرهنة الطيفية للمصفوفات شبه
الموجبة التعريف والتي نوقشت في الدرس السابق. هنا لا نرى أي قيم ذاتية تظهر صراحة كما في التحليل
الطيفي لكن تذكّروا أن القيم الذاتية للمصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف هي دائماً أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة، وتذكّروا أيضاً أننا
لا نشترط أن تكون هذه المتجهات s₀ إلى s_ متجهات وحدة. فما يمكننا فعله هو أخذ الجذور التربيعية
للقيم الذاتية وضربها في متجهات الوحدة الذاتية التي نحصل عليها من التحليل الطيفي للحصول على هذه
المتجهات s₀ إلى s_. في الحقيقة ليس مهماً لهذا البرهان أن تكون هذه المتجهات متعامدة. نحصل على ذلك
من التحليل الطيفي لكننا لن نستخدمه هنا. وإن كان لدينا تعبير مختلف لـ J(فاي) بهذا الشكل لم يأتِ من
المبرهنة الطيفية فسيكون ذلك جيداً أيضاً. الآن نحلّل كل متجه من هذه المتجهات كما هو موضّح على الشاشة و
هذا تماماً كما لو كانت هذه المتجهات متجهات حالة كمّية لزوج من الأنظمة XY و
كنا نجري قياس أساس قياسي على النظام X. للتوضيح لسنا نقيس أي شيء هنا، نحن فقط نكتب هذه المتجهات بهذا الشكل وهو
ممكن دائماً. والآن تأتي الحيلة: نعرّف مصفوفات Kraus من A₀ إلى A_ بانتزاع كيت
a من مقدمة هذه المتجهات s₀ إلى s_ وقلبها لتصبح برا a بدلاً
من كيت a ولصقها على الجهة اليمنى كما هو موضّح في المعادلة على الشاشة. إحدى طرق التفكير
في هذا هي أننا نطوي هذه المتجهات لتشكيل مصفوفات، بحيث لو رصفنا أعمدة Aₖ فوق بعضها
لحصلنا على sₖ مجدداً. فهذه المصفوفات لها نفس عناصر المتجهات المقابلة تماماً لكننا
أعدنا ترتيب العناصر بشكل مختلف للحصول على مصفوفات. لكن يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في هذه المصفوفات بشكل رمزي بحت بترميز ديراك
كما هو مكتوب هنا. والآن في هذه المرحلة هناك سؤال واضح: لماذا يجب أن ينجح هذا؟ حسناً لنتجنب التفكير كثيراً في
سبب نجاحه ولنتحقق ببساطة من أنه ينجح. لفعل ذلك لنعرّف تحويلاً جديداً وهو التحويل المعرّف بهذه
المصفوفات حيث نعاملها كمصفوفات Kraus. ما يمكننا فعله الآن هو حساب تمثيل Choi
لهذا التحويل الجديد وسنرى أنه يساوي تمثيل Choi للتحويل فاي الذي بدأنا به. و
لأن تمثيلات Choi أمينة فهذا يعني أن التحويلين متساويان فعلاً. لن أتناول الجبر في هذا الفيديو، يمكنكم
التحقق من ذلك بأنفسكم. إنه آلي جداً وتمرين جيد، وكل ما تحتاجونه لذلك موجود
هنا على الشاشة. لم نقل شيئاً بعد عن الشرطين الثانيين في المربعين لكنهما
اتضح أنهما متكافئان. وإحدى طرق إثبات ذلك هي التحقق من المعادلة المعروضة في أسفل
الشاشة. الحرف T هنا بالمناسبة يشير إلى تبديل المصفوفة والذي يمكنكم بدلاً من ذلك التفكير فيه كالتحويل
الخطي الذي يحوّل كيت a برا b إلى كيت b برا a. وهو شيء مطلوب فقط لجعل الصيغة تعمل. فباختصار
هناك بالتأكيد بعض الجبر المطلوب لهذا الاستلزام لكن كما قلت كله آلي إلى حد كبير،
بشكل أساسي "ألعاب مؤشرات" كما يسمّيها البعض. لكن إذا عملتم عليه ومنحتم عقلكم فرصة لهضمه قد تجدون
أنكم تخرجون بفهم أفضل لكيفية ارتباط تمثيلات Choi وتمثيلات Kraus. الاستلزام الثالث يسمح لنا
بالانتقال من تمثيل Kraus لتحويل فاي حيث الشرط المعتاد متحقق إلى تمثيل Stinespring. هذا الاستلزام مشابه جداً
في روحه للاستلزام السابق بمعنى أنه آلي ويمكن رؤيته والتحقق منه بمصطلحات جبرية بحتة.
الفكرة في الحقيقة بسيطة جداً. ما يمكننا فعله هو أخذ مصفوفات Kraus وتشكيل جزء من مصفوفة أكبر برصفها
فوق بعضها كما هو موضّح على الشاشة. بمجرد اكتمالها ستعطينا المصفوفة الأحادية U لتمثيل
Stinespring. المصفوفات الأحادية يجب أن تكون مربعة لذا سنحتاج لملء أعمدة إضافية
بقدر ما نحتاج لذلك. لكن لن يهم ماهيتها طالما حصلنا على مصفوفة
أحادية. إذا تجاهلنا مؤقتاً القلق بشأن كون U أحادية وركّزنا فقط على التحويل الخطي المعرّف بتمثيل
Stinespring الذي نحصل عليه من هذه المصفوفة U، فإن ما نجده هو أن التحويل يساوي
التحويل الأصلي فاي المعرّف بتمثيل Kraus الذي بدأنا به. هذا جزء آخر من البرهان لن أتناوله في هذا الفيديو. يمكنكم
إيجاد التفاصيل في المحتوى المكتوب لهذا الدرس لكن قد تفضّلون أخذ بعض الوقت والعمل عليه بأنفسكم. فقط تذكّروا
كالمعتاد في السلسلة أننا نستخدم اصطلاح ترتيب Qiskit لتفسير المخطط فـ W وG
ستتوافقان مع عوامل الجداء التنسوري على الجهة اليسرى في المعادلات. وبالمناسبة إذا عملتم
على ذلك ستجدون أنه لأن لدينا كيت 0 برا 0 كعامل تنسوري على الجهة اليسرى في المعادلة
التي نحتاج للتحقق منها فإن الجزء الوحيد من U الذي له أي صلة هو الجزء المعطى بمصفوفات Kraus. فطالما ملأنا
أعمدة U بطريقة تجعلها أحادية فنحن بخير. لكن بالطبع هذا يتطلب أن تكون الأعمدة المشكّلة من A₀ إلى A_
عند رصفها فوق بعضها متعامدة معيارية. وهنا يأتي دور الشرط الذي نضعه على تمثيلات Kraus
وهو فعلاً مكافئ تماماً لكون الأعمدة متعامدة معيارية. العلاقات الرياضية اللازمة لاستخلاص هذا
الاستنتاج موضّحة في أسفل الشاشة. فتفضّلوا بالإيقاف والتحقق إن اخترتم أو مجدداً
راجعوا المحتوى المكتوب لمزيد من التفاصيل. باختصار ما يحدث هنا في هذا الاستلزام و
في الاستلزام السابق هو أننا نصف نفس العمليات الرياضية بطرق مختلفة لكن متكافئة.
القلب النابض لكل ذلك هو أساساً ضرب المصفوفات. الاستلزام الرابع والأخير يثبت أنه إذا كان لدينا
تمثيل Stinespring لتحويل ما فإن ذلك التحويل يجب أن يكون فعلاً قناة صالحة. وكما أشرت
سابقاً تناولنا هذا الاستلزام عندما ناقشنا تمثيلات Stinespring. باختصار وبمصطلحات
مختلفة قليلاً: إدخال نظام مساحة عمل مهيّأ هو قناة صالحة. وذلك لأن الجداء التنسوري لمصفوفة
كثافة ثابتة مع مصفوفة كثافة معيّنة يعطينا دائماً مصفوفة كثافة وهو تحويل خطي بفضل ثنائية خطية
الجداءات التنسورية. العمليات الأحادية هي دائماً قنوات صالحة كما ناقشت سابقاً في الدرس. حساب الأثر الجزئي لنظام هو قناة صالحة لأن
الأثر الجزئي تحويل خطي يحوّل دائماً مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات كثافة. وأخيراً تركيب
القنوات هو دائماً قناة وهذا أمر بسيط جداً لكنه يستحق الملاحظة بحد ذاته. ومع
الاستلزامات الأربعة التي تناولناها للتو أثبتنا تكافؤ تمثيلات القنوات الثلاثة مع
التعريف الأصلي للقناة. بالتحديد بدأنا بتعريف القناة ورأينا كيف يستلزم ذلك التعريف أن تمثيل Choi
الخاص بها يستوفي بالضرورة شرطين أساسيين. ثم رأينا كيف تسمح لنا هذه الشروط بإيجاد تمثيل Kraus الذي بدوره
يسمح لنا بإيجاد تمثيل Stinespring. وأخيراً رأينا أن وجود تمثيل Stinespring يكشف أن لدينا
فعلاً قناة صالحة. بالطبع هناك تفاصيل تقنية في ذلك وليس الأمر بسيطاً بالضرورة خاصة
عندما ترونه لأول مرة. لكن المثير والجدير بالملاحظة هنا أن هذه الاستلزامات مرتّبة بطريقة تجعل الأمور
سهلة قدر الإمكان فعلاً. وفي الرياضيات لا ينبغي أبداً الشعور بالخجل من أخذ الطريق السهل.
مثلاً ليس واضحاً أبداً أن كل قناة لها تمثيل Stinespring أو تمثيل Kraus
لكن من السهل نسبياً استنتاج أن تمثيل Choi لكل قناة يستوفي الشرطين اللذين ربطناهما به. وهذا
يسمح لنا باتباع مسار جبري إلى حد كبير نحو التمثيلين الآخرين. وبالمثل
الاستلزام الأخير من تمثيل Stinespring إلى التعريف هو أيضاً مباشر نسبياً و
يسمح لنا بالاستنتاج أننا نحصل فقط على قنوات ولا تحويلات أخرى من تمثيلات Choi بشرط أن
الشروط المطلوبة متحققة. وكما ألمحت سابقاً فإن طريقة تبرير هذه الاستلزامات آلية بما يكفي للسماح لنا بسهولة بالتحويل
بين التمثيلات. وإذا عدتم إلى بعض الأمثلة التي تناولناها سابقاً في الدرس ستجدون أنه من الممكن فعلاً
التحويل بين التمثيلات وأحياناً بسهولة ومباشرة تامة. وهذه نهاية
الدرس الذي كان كله عن القنوات. تحدثنا عن ماهيتها وألقينا نظرة على بعض الأمثلة الأساسية. ناقشنا ثلاث طرق لتمثيل القنوات
وتعمّقنا في بعض التفاصيل التقنية التي تثبت تكافؤ هذه التمثيلات.
آمل أن تنضموا إليّ في الدرس القادم الذي سيكون كله عن القياسات في الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمّية. إلى اللقاء حينها.